when you get a real good idea you should
act on it
if you hold yourself back because of
fear your life actually comes to a stop
because nothing gets better than it is
the success that I've enjoyed is because
of the mentors or the coaches I've had I
would do exactly what they tell me need
motivation watch a top ten with believe
nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chill in today's lesson to a
man who went from not finishing school
and being broke to becoming a master of
the law of attraction and being featured
in a hit film the secret he's Bob
Proctor and here's my take on his top
ten Rose success vol 3
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one act on your ideas hello there I'm
welcome
do you know almost everyone has a great
idea and they're going to execute the
great idea I have all kinds of people
come to me I've got a great idea I'd
like to share with you what they do is
they want me to execute their idea why
don't they execute their idea when you
get a real good idea you should act on
it people have ideas starting a business
I've started a number of different
businesses question is where to start
you start where you are and you start
with what you've got that's all you need
when you start where you are and with
what you've got and you bring your mind
to focus on that idea you will attract
everything to you that you need you are
taught see key first is Kingdom in its
righteousness and all these things will
be given to us see when you learn to
focus on something you get on a
frequency and when you're in that
frequency you start to attract whatever
you want you may not have any money you
may not have the resources that you need
to execute to build it into something
big that doesn't matter all the
resources that you need to do anything
you want to do is already here
but you've got to get in touch with them
you've got to get in harmony with them
and boom you'll rush them into your life
you'll attract the money the people the
thoughts the things everything you need
you'll attract to you so where do you
start you always start where you are and
you start with what you've got
don't be looking at what you don't have
think of what you do have fall in love
with your idea and get it rolling
rule number two believe you tell
yourself a lie often enough you're gonna
start to believe it and way around 1900
William James said believe and your
belief will create the fact it's got to
be believed you've got to believe it and
if there's no belief it ain't going to
happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea and
that makes all kinds of things happen
when you believe it
there's no quitting you never quit it
doesn't matter what happens you don't
quit quitting is never an option I the
people that quit they never really
bought into the idea in the first place
see you've got it you you get it on
three levels the second you think of
something you've got it intellectually
when you get emotionally involved you've
got it on a spiritual or emotional level
well then that expresses itself through
the body body's just an instrument of
your mind
and so when you're really buying into it
you literally fuse with it Neville said
you fuse with it and this causes all
kinds of things to happen you're dealing
with electronics you're dealing with
energy like the second you think
something that's all you need see you
live on frequencies you think on
frequencies your phone operates on
frequencies and it's like magic and
you're you're in Romania is right I'm in
Toronto yes if I've got your number on
my phone I could take a picture
something hit it like that you've got it
in Romania simultaneous with me sending
it because when you get into the mind
there isn't any time or space it's just
immediate yeah well though you're living
on frequencies now when you think of
something what you've done is you've
flipped your brain onto a higher
frequency
the very fact you can see it is all the
proof you need to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency and
then you will attract whatever is on
that frequency all the good you need to
manifest the idea rule number three
overcome fear overcoming fear is one of
the greatest moves a person can make
first of all we have to ask yourself
what causes fear fears caused by
ignorance not knowing and if we're gonna
go and do anything new if we're gonna
break out of a paradigm if we're gonna
change habit patterns we're wandering
into an area we've never been
and you know fear stops most people
you'll find people afraid to talk to a
stranger you'll find individuals afraid
to stand up and ask the question in
front of other people
you'll find salespeople afraid to make a
sales call afraid to ask for the order
stop and think of how confining that is
a person is putting themself into a
small cell but it's in their own mind
the doors aren't locked they can open
and you can walk away to freedom if you
learn to overcome fear when you face
fear it leaves you face the thing you
fear and it'll leave you that's really
the secret of it in fact if you hold
yourself back because of fear your life
actually comes to a stop because nothing
gets better than it is you've got to be
courageous now Crete just people aren't
without fear courageous people are the
ones that face their fear I think Eddie
Rickenbacker pointed that out the great
pilot don't let fear stop you make up
your mind you're gonna step out and do
it stop and think of the number of
people that are in jobs that they don't
like and they're afraid to leave or
people in relationships that are
destructive and they're afraid to leave
this is a terrible way to live and it's
not necessary
it's just caused by ignorance and when
we step out and do something we gain in
their awareness we develop an
understanding and like that the fear is
gone make up your mind that fear is not
going to stop you from doing the thing
you really want to do step out and do it
today rule number four visualize and
when I was 26 I had a man that sat down
with me and he said why don't you change
the way you're living it never entered
my mind that I could and looking back
and thinking about it I think there's
all kinds of people wandering the planet
there's all kinds of athletes that are
not getting the results they want and
they don't know they can change them
right only one person can see there's
only one person in the whole universe
that can change Bob and that's Bob yeah
there's only one person can change Dave
in that state now we get inspired by
other people we get help from other
people but we've got to do it ourselves
and he gave me thinking for rich and he
said if you do exactly what I tell you
you can have anything you want well I
didn't believe that but he was so
adamant about I believed he believed and
so I started to listen to him and I set
a goal I wanted some money
I wanted 25,000 hours no this was in
1961 so it was more money than it is
today but I didn't even know anyone with
$25,000 he said listen write it on a
card keep reading the book keep doing
what I tell you so I started to hear
people talking about earning money and
there was one guy said there's good
money cleaning floors you should you
should clean floors well I wasn't proud
I'd clean floors and he said but you
should do it for yourself now for
somebody else so he told me where I
could buy a use for him in some buckets
and mops but I had to borrow a thousand
dollars well I was at the point where
nobody wanted to touch it with money and
I often say I wouldn't have lend it to
me right as I wouldn't pay it back not
that I didn't want to I just couldn't
but I found a guy he lent me the
thousand dollars when you borrow sue me
because I have a question I know you
when you borrow that thousand because
you owed people money already
you had explained that to people you
know you were just finding yourself but
did you have a different feeling about
when you borrowed this thousand that
quite possibly you were actually gonna
be able to just to pay this back this
time you know something if I hadn't had
that feeling I wouldn't have got the
money I got it from a guy I knew his
name al Kuiper he was running and I
didn't know him he had a trust company
was like a bank on Danforth Avenue in
Toronto and I went in I read a book
where it says go to one bank of him with
Kevin go to another one well I ended up
sitting in his office and he said what
do you want this money for son and I
told him I was gonna build a cleaning
company it was gonna be big I had a
dream
and I had to explain it alternate he
said I think you'll do it
i'ma lend you the money faith but I knew
when I was doing this I had a picture I
had a dream you see yep
and within a year I was earning a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars a year i had my building up to
fifteen thousand dollars a month working
for myself less than five years we're
working at Toronto Montreal Boston
Cleveland Atlanta and London England I
had my own company opening offices all
over the place rule number five know
what you want why most people don't get
what they want out of life is it well
they don't know what they want that's
right you see I got this
and then I gotta roll nightingale's
condensed narration of this on a long
playing record and I'd listened that
record over and over and over again one
day I was in the business in the
cleaning business I had sales people and
I had them listen to this record every
morning we listen to this record and one
day I said you know I'd love to meet him
and I didn't know who or a light yo was
he was a voice on a record that was it I
didn't even know where he lived and a
young guy that worked with me he said no
you wouldn't he's if you wanted to meet
him you'd go and meet him I thought damn
he's right so I phoned and I got an
appointment with him now at the time he
was the most listened to man in the
history of the broadcasting industry he
was a radio broadcaster and not an easy
guy to get to but I got to meet with for
an hour I flew to Chicago I spent an
hour with them and when I was leaving I
said Earl what's the big deal you know
I mean what's it all about he says
there's no big deal he said it's it's
very simply says simply decide what you
love to do and then dedicate your life
to it he's the problem with most people
they don't know what they love to do
they never take the time to sit and ask
them
what they're doing is trying I think I
can get her and good money here I could
do it good you know it's Rick and the
earn some money it's not what they love
to do well I was sitting there you know
I had offices all over the place I had a
lot of people I was earning a lot of
money and I I got excited because I knew
exactly what I want to do I'm gonna do
what he was doing
and I made up my mind sitting in his
office that be somewhere around 1965
that I was going to go back and I was
gonna work with him and in 1968 I moved
to Chicago I left my own company I moved
to Chicago when they started to work
with him rule number six be more patient
here patience is a virtue
I suppose it probably is but I think
patience real patience is an expression
of deep understanding to see everything
happens when it's supposed to happen
everything in this universe happens by
law we set targets and we need things to
happen we need something to come or
someone to do something and frequently
we get frustrated because it isn't
happening when we think it should happen
our problem is we're not thinking we
believe we're in charge we are not in
charge we are in charge of building the
idea and holding the idea everything
else happens automatically
all ideas have a gestation or an
incubation period I'm told when we plant
a carrot in the area of the world that I
live it takes approximately seven days
for that carrot to grow and manifest in
form when the seed for the babies
planted it takes approximately 280 days
and we're usually patient we will wait
to 280 days why because we know it's
going to take approximately 280 days
well just because we don't know how long
it's going to take doesn't mean that it
isn't operating by the same
everything operates by law so if we cane
and understanding that all the ideas in
our mind will ultimately move into form
that's what Andrew Carnegie taught
Napoleon Hill Carnegie was Hill's mentor
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered but begin it wants to close
itself in the most convenient and
appropriate form available you might
want to listen to that two or three
times burn it into your mind gain an
understanding of it and you will know
that whatever you're working on takes a
period of time no one knows what the
gestation period is for an idea
we only know we can shorten it through
concentration through focus and when you
understand that who have become more
patient and when you're more patient and
living in a much more beautiful
vibration you'll be a more pleasant
person to be around you will enjoy your
song patience it's the result of
understanding rule number seven tap into
your genius if you really analyze your
beliefs you'll change them I had a
friend one time I I was trying to figure
out where do beliefs come from how do
you because all religion and all science
will tell you you got to believe it
William James from Harvard 1900 he said
believe in your belief will create the
fact so believe this is an interesting
word you're gonna believe it and I was
having lunch with a mentor one time and
he said our belief system is based upon
our evaluation of something frequently
if we reevaluate a situation our belief
about that situation will change it was
like bells were going off my head
because I was trying to understand
belief how do you change your belief
well he told me yes through revaluation
and so I started to evaluate myself and
reevaluate what I was doing it took me
nine and a half years but I figured out
why I changed and it was the repetition
of information thank you you're in
sports you know it's repetition yep
repetition repetition well
but practice doesn't make you perfect
perfect breakfast makes you perfect
there's a big difference
great point and so I found that the part
of our mind that controls our behavior
is not the part of our mind that gathers
information school deals with the part
of your mind that gathers information
and so we gather all kinds of
information and if we can remember it
they give us a test we pass the test we
get that degree and we're educated
that's not education at all that is
gathering information education as he'll
pointed out comes from the Latin adieu
Khomeini is reduced to developer to drug
from within
we have genius in us we have absolute
perfection in us and what we have to do
is learn how to tap into that to let it
out but we have a part of our mind that
controls our behavior and that's where a
paradigm is and the paradigm literally
controls our behavior I don't care what
you're doing if you not altering the
paradigm you're not going to improve
your results there's so much about
ourselves we never learn the part of our
mind that controls us is our intellect
our subconscious where the paradigm is
but we're trained to live through our
senses we're trained to go by what we
see hear smell taste touch and we've got
to understand that we've got this genius
within us and if we will consciously
gain an awareness and understanding of
how to alter the paradigm that's
controlling our behavior when we learn
that we can start to improve life just
like that and there's no end to what
we're capable of doing we're conditioned
genetically all mums DNA and all dad's
DNA becomes our DNA there's two
particles of energy come together that's
the moment of conception 280 days later
we make our debut on the planet then
were programmed by our environment
because our subconscious mind which is
totally deductive it has no ability to
reject the subconscious mind is amoral
it's like the earth it doesn't care what
you plant but it'll return what you
planned romaine d'el used a beautiful
example on the strangest secret he said
you can plant nightshade a deadly poison
not 1/16 of an inch away
you can plant corn is sweet food
will grow with just as great an
abundance as the other and that's the
way your subjective mind works you put
the wrong idea in it will grow put the
right idea and it will grow we have the
ability to change what's in there we did
not program it it was programmed through
genetic history where the confluence of
a genetic pool that goes back for
generations that's at birth and then
environmentally and we have the ability
to alter all that who liber8 get good
Mentors
see any success I've had I've had
because I've got great mentors and I'm a
good student now until I was 26 I was a
terrible student when I picked up this
book I become a great student I've got
thousands of bucks I have an office at
home in my home it's got a couple of
thousand bucks in it and I built a
studio and I've got a couple of thousand
bucks in the studio and I love reading
but the success that I've enjoyed is
because of the mentors or the coaches
I've had I would do exactly what they
tell me and if I coach somebody today
and they don't do exactly what I tell
them I don't coach them anymore
just like that it's all over it's not
ready well they're not there it's not
that only that they're not ready but if
I'm gonna coach somebody and they're not
doing what I tell them I'm wasting my
time and and theirs too now if they want
to waste their time that's their
prerogative I'm not gonna waste my rule
number nine practice forgiveness
you know forgiving is one of the most
freeing concept anybody can ever get
involved with most people look at
forgiveness as helping the other person
somebody hurts you somebody does you're
wrong but you're gonna forgive them
you're gonna be kind to them it is
nothing to do with the other person it
has to do with yourself that's really
what it has to do see forgiveness is a
cleansing concept it's clearing the mind
of all negativity clearing the mind of
anything that might go wrong it's a very
freeing concept if you were to do some
harm to me
and I forgive you you haven't got
anything to do with it it's I'm letting
go of something that was bothering me
that's negative and I don't want to hold
on to that forgiving freeze the one
that's doing the forgiving it's a
phenomenal concept forgive means to let
go of completely abandoned let it go
don't hold on to it
Joe somebody does you're wrong you have
to ask himself
ask yourself ever wonder why they would
do that there's something bothering them
they're not really trying to hurt you
it's something that's bothering them let
it go just forgive it forgive the idea
and I guarantee you you'll feel a lot
better and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
develop confidence and one of the
greatest hang-ups that people have is
the belief in themselves they they
suffer from something called self-doubt
many years ago I read something it was
by um Ralph Waldo Emerson it was this
essay on self-reliance that's what we
want to do we want to rely on self and
in that he said there would come a time
in every person's education when they
realized that envy is ignorance and
imitation is suicide so many people look
at someone that's doing very well
possibly in the same field they're in
and envy them do you know what that's
saying that's saying I don't know that I
have the same mental faculties you've
got I'm drawing on the same potential
that you're drawing on there is only one
mind I don't know that so I'm gonna in
view thinking you can do something I'm
not able to do the truth is if you can
do it I can do it envy is ignorance it's
not knowing that and he said imitation
is suicide do you know that nothing in
this universe would move in the precise
order it moves in your absence
that's true everything in the universe
is essential you take any part away from
anything it's not complete and
everything in the universe moves in a
very precise way so do you see we
shouldn't even want to be like anybody
else because we are unique we are truly
unique there's something like about us
said you'll never find in another person
were unique and we've got the godlike
ability to think now what is self-doubt
self-doubt is the opposite of
self-confidence confidence comes from
understanding like I would imagine
you're confident you can drive your car
in fact you're so confident that you'll
be talking to somebody on the phone
you'll get in the car you'll start the
car you'll Drive and you'll drive maybe
four or five blocks not even be unaware
of what you've done it's all done
automatic your concentration is on the
conversation you're on now when you
first got in a car you couldn't do that
the car was probably jumping all over
the place and you thought you'd never
learned how to drive it but you learned
how to drive it now you're quite
confident you're confident that you can
get dressed when you get up in the
morning when you're a little boy or a
little girl you couldn't do that you had
to be taught to do it well you know self
confidence comes like all confidence it
comes with knowledge and the more you
study you the more you understand who
you are the more confident you'll become
in your ability to do whatever it is
you're doing and you'll know that if you
like confidence in an area it's because
you liked information in that area never
doubt yourself and when you do
understand that the cause of that doubt
is not lying within you it's in wrong
thinking it's you not understanding who
you are study yourself self study will
develop self confidence and self
confidence eliminates self doubt
now I've got a really special bonus tip
from Bob on how to think and grow rich
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that is time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from Washington others IDEO to actually
taking
so here we go question number one what
idea do you need to act on today number
two how can you believe more in this
idea and number three what mentor can
you learn from to help you believe more
consistently
what did you do to learn about yourself
you said you went around as many summer
I attended seminars I went and listened
to different speakers who taught
something about the mind I think the
answer is in our mind if we'll start
studying and trying to understand their
mind okay let me get with let me get
back to you if I can what did you learn
about Bob Procter during that study well
I learned that the biggest part of me
you'll never see it's non-physical and
what you see here in the physical body
is nothing but the physical
manifestation of the higher side of my
personality and of course that's true
with you and you know man suits on the
camera it's true of everyone and what we
have to study I think is how does this
non-physical part of my mind work what
happens when I think where do thoughts
come from how was this chair built
somebody had to think thoughts are
everywhere and we pull thoughts into our
mind and we build pictures or images in
our mind ok what we want to understand
is that's a non-physical side of
ourselves that's doing that if I can
build an image of something in my mind
I'm quite capable of building a physical
replica of it in my world so if I build
an image of me as a happy relaxed person
I can live like that if I build an image
of myself as being prosperous I can
become prosperous so if we think rich we
will be rich absolutely we are already
rich just short of money ok those of us
that like to acquire more money and or
happiness or whatever we see success
those of us to want to reach the goals
that we've set for ourselves we do it
first by well the first thing you do is
sit down and decide what you want if
it's money you want how much money lots
of money well nobody knows how much lots
that is so you've got to be specific ok
you write down on a card exactly what
you want and you carry that card around
and read it often now this is what I
learned in this book Think and Grow Rich
and it's what I teach in the seminars
I'll teach people how to set goals but
you decide exactly what you want and
then you start
now you're gonna have thoughts come to
your mind of why you can't get it mm-hmm
you have the ability and your conscious
mind to reject that idea kick it out of
your mind thinking of why you can't do
something is never going to do you any
good and keep thinking until you start
to think of thoughts of how you can do
it and the way will be showing to you it
comes in the form of images in our mind
think of how you can and not why you
can't raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that mm-hmm that
people your passion and not one drop of
myself work depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean
if you guys like this video I want to
learn from Bob's mentor Earl Nightingale
I highly recommend checking out the top
10 we did on him the link is right next
to me continue to believe and I'll see
you there
just one great idea can completely
revolutionize your work and as a result
your life